uh peter thiel has told the story where
uh i guess some of the folks from paypal
uh went to antigua i believe it is uh
and there was some sort of like
encryption and uh money conference uh
and his thought process is that uh
satoshi must have been there uh one did
you go to the conference and two any uh
any thoughts in terms of that theory
yeah i wasn't so i wasn't at that one i
think at that conference the state of
the art in this crypto world uh was sort
of e-gold
and the idea i guess was that you would
get
the certificates that were redeemable
for gold and you could move them around
online
and you know the paypal was was sort of
a reaction against that saying no these
systems are too complicated they don't
really make sense again like dollars
work just fine
uh we weren't trying to upend the
currency itself we were just trying to
make it more convenient
um but yeah it's um it's interesting how
there were these predecessors to bitcoin
yeah well i think it's one of the key
pieces right like there's 40 years of r
d that went into the creation of bitcoin
so people always say oh the first one
never works and you know they always
jump to the aols or the the myspaces but
you know it's probably i don't know the
15th or 20th version it seems to seems
to be working